cela dit je voudrais quand même vous
tenir au courant d'une actualité qui
n'est pas j'allais dire qu'il n'est pas
très sérieuse mais si voyons margaret
sino land c'est sérieux alors il n'y a
pas de raison que celle à ringo ne le
soit pas vous savez il ya au cours du
petit rapporteur jacques martin et
stéphane collaro ont évoqué le problème
de la séparation de ses deux vedettes de
notre show business à nous qui n'a rien
à voir avec le show-business royale
britannique
mais toujours est il que certains
d'entre vous ont peut être été eu avec
le sourire je l'espère et comprenez le
bien comme ça on peut être été ému de
certains titres qui faisait la une de
certains journaux paraissant le lundi ce
à quoi du reste stéphane collaro a fait
allusion et hier au cours du petit
rapporteur
alors nous nous voulions savoir non pas
l'avis du concierge de chela mais l'avis
des intéressés eux mêmes c'est à dire
monsieur et madame wilhite 4 puisque
c'est le monde ringo vous nous apprenez
quelque chose à regarder la télévision à
lierre il paraît que ça a été assez
virulent on était en vacances on a on
n'a pas à vrai dire on n'a pas lu
donc
on n'est pas au courant de ce qui s'est
passé mais d'après ce que vous dites
enfin apparemment c'est une fausse
nouvelle puisqu'on était saoul et de
tous les trois mêmes avec des pics à la
montagne
ea a priori on n'a pas l'air de manière
d'être en pleine forme
ça va alors la conclusion c'est à ces
journalistes si on sait que les
nouvelles vont vite et elles sont
souvent wii et plus ça aussi que ça ça
nous amuse beaucoup de lire notre vie
privée dans certains journaux
alors quid maintenant le lundi matin
ajoute le journal ce qui se passe
ouf nous voici rassurés vous êtes
rassuré jacques martin va être rassuré
collaro doit baigner dans le bonheur et
nous mêmes aussi ils sont réunis ils
n'ont pas l'intention